how much is a script worth it's a very
good question
it depends basically what it is that the
writer is trying to get out of it a
script can be a tool a script can be a
great showcase of what a writer can
bring to Hollywood bring to the market
but that's just one aspect of spec
screenwriting where you're trying to
present yourself as a writer for hire at
which point a script has an unlimited
amount of potential in terms of price
because you can build a career off that
mindset if you're going in is a one time
pop off script where you're going to
write something specifically that's
marketable and sellable you can probably
flip it for a cheap deal if you're able
to secure a purchase generally you'll
probably be offered an option agreement
which means that a company is going to
borrow the rights to it and see if they
can generate a film adaptation from your
script if you're one of the lucky ones
who's able to sell a script for purchase
and actually receive a check for it
upfront it's generally worth about 10 to
15 percent of what the actual
out-of-pocket budget will be to produce
the film and in most cases what would
that be
well I get four four and let's say a
made-for-television movie what could a
screenwriter expect to see budgets a
budget is a very relative term because a
budget is you you give a budget for a
group of financier zorp resellers if
you're trying to get money from and
you're going to give them a certain
number so that you can gain a little bit
more from them if you are on set you
might give a different budget number so
that you can avoid certain issues
potentially with contractors maybe
trying to take advantage of you tax
codes unions so there's a certain budget
level might be presented there and then
the final budget that's actually
released after the fact could include
whole marketing components that were
never factored in early on so budgets
are pretty relative
so how much one movie might be budgeted
for versus another is all over the map
it depends on caste it depends on how
much collateral was secured in advance
it's kind of all over the map short but
what could a screenwriter expect to get
for their like just just bottom-line
like if someone says you know should I
really invest all this time in honing
this craft of mine and and and coming up
with multiple drafts what could I expect
to see from one one script my belief is
this what a screenwriter can really
expect out of a single script I don't
think a screenwriter should really look
at it in that way I think a screenwriter
could potentially get you know a couple
thousand dollars up to tens of thousands
of dollars for a single script if it
just nails it screenwriting is really
more of a craft and it's a kind of a
lifelong investment I believe of time
and I think that a writer is gonna make
a lot more money if they're writing what
Hollywood needs overall because then
they can become a go-to writer they can
become a go-to writer that production
companies like the ones that I work for
are always in need of that you know when
we have a film that we're developing and
we have a project that we have funded we
can call up a writer that we know we
trust who can deliver that kind of
content quickly and we can turn a very
quick deal fifteen thousand twenty-five
thousand dollars for a couple of you
know drafts of a script and that can be
an ongoing situation and you can write
three four scripts a year in that
scenario if you're writing on spec in
the hopes that Hollywood will just
perfectly align with what you're
pitching to them it's a very very very
tough daunting challenge to be able to
actually get a transaction on that I
would say slim to nil of making it
happen that's why I think it's more
important for writers if they're gonna
write spec which is a requirement in the
beginning right with Hollywood needs
focus on those goldmine John Rose that
must have content that the system once
and use it as a sample of what you can
bring to the marketplace and what your
value
as a writer and then you can become a
go-to writer so an answer the big answer
to the question is how much can you make
it's all over the map it's more about
not looking at it as a one-off how much
can I make on this script it's more how
is this script going to aid my career as
a writer which a writer can make a very
substantial amount of money if they play
the game right sure but for a first time
a newbie let's say a two thousand really
could be the lowest like the low end of
what they could expect to see a two
thousand could easily be an like an
option buy-in so mm II might say okay
there's there's something to this script
we like the idea we're not convinced
that anyone is really interested or
maybe they go you know we just had an
interesting conversation with company
XYZ last week and they seem to like
something like this maybe we put an
option on the script of fifteen hundred
twenty-five hundred dollars as a as a
courtesy of let's borrow the rights for
a period of time so we can pitch it to
this company and then if a deal takes
place fantastic the writer gets a payout
the production company gets the script
if no deal takes place it's much less
risk for the production company or the
producer or whomever is giving the
option and so in those instances that
might be the best option that might be
the best opportunity a writer gets on
that script it's really hit or miss it's
really it or miss
you